now we have women that are really are
I would say genetic like masterpieces
almost maybe it's not the right word but
like like top genes right they're
they're stunningly beautiful like
absolutely stunning and great bodies
very friendly and nice but
they still are not exempt to being
modern women the culture like women are
so susceptible to propaganda the culture
just has really ruined us we have Sofia
Vergara we we covered last week she's
getting a divorce so this woman is 51
and twice divorced she's been ensnared
in a legal battle with another
ex-boyfriend that she never married
because she wanted to destroy the Frozen
embryos they've created via IVF
and he didn't her most recent divorce is
allegedly because her ex wanted kids and
she didn't but hey she's partying in
Italy in a swimsuit this is exemplary of
what is wrong with Western Society
there's no shame in being single but the
very few people are being called to a
lifetime lifetime of singlehood no one
is called to a series of broken
marriages single doesn't look so great
when you're 70 and alone it's really
interesting because it's almost like we
live in like
a fake world because these women like
they get their faces Frozen and like
they get all these like natural stuff
where they don't look their age but
think about an average like 55 year old
woman that you know wearing a swimsuit
like this it's almost like we're living
in this La La Land like I'm sorry a 55
year old woman should not be moving like
a 25 year old woman this should not be
controversial I don't care if you're
single or married you're supposed to be
an example to the younger women
yeah like I don't even wear swimsuits
like that and I'm half your age lady
like and this is the crazy thing it's
like we have all of these old ladies
living like they're 25 when they are not
and we have a society that pushes them
to live in this delusion when literally
this woman is at the end of her life you
know I mean she's gonna maybe make it to
like 70 75 80. and what is that what
does the end of life look like you know
and and I really believe women
really start to feel lonely when looks
start to fade because when your looks
start to fade you kind of start to see
who who loves you for you and not your
looks and I've heard this from older
women where like it's kind of like you
really you go through a phase where
like when your looks start to go you you
realize a lot of like
the guys around you are just you know
there for one thing I mean obviously
we're red pill but you know and but but
it's like
what is what does life look like
at 70 for her when her looks are
actually gone because I don't know
maybe she'll look good at 70 I don't
know